just want to ask you about our latest
Westminster accounts report looking at
second jobs you yourself have worked
almost 500 hours in this Parliament
earning a hundred a thousand pounds all
within the rules of course but how do
you think that plays with the public
very briefly
I focus on my constituents I focus on
chair and my select committee and I
always have
um and I think you know you should be
very careful about sneering MPS and
making out that MPS are are not focusing
on their jobs 99.9 of MPS I've met in
Westminster are focused on doing their
job and doing the right thing be very
careful before you run our profession
into the ground we're out of time I bet
you are okay
Steve Ryan thanks very much indeed thank
you